by now everybody knows about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which includes the
Avengers along with various other
superheroes throughout film and
television with Marvel success a bunch
of other Studios have jumped in on the
shared universe trend with varying
degrees of success the most obvious one
is DC's extended universe this is most
similar to Marvel because it also has a
team of superheroes with the Justice
League
DC's films have been financially
successful but less universally praised
than Marvel's franchise they'll try to
turn that around this year with the
release of Wonder Woman and Justice
League but what about non superhero
universes when Warner Brothers released
Godzilla in 2014 many people didn't
realize that it was just the first part
of a shared giant monster universe Kong
Skull Island released this past March is
part of that same world future plans
include a Godzilla King Kong clash and a
Godzilla king of the monsters team-up
which would basically be like The
Avengers but with giant kaiju speaking
of monsters this summer's reboot of the
mummy is part of universals plan to
launch a new universe featuring their
classic monsters including Frankenstein
The Wolfman and Swamp Thing we'll see if
that works out Godzilla and Frankenstein
are both well-known monsters but there's
some new kids they're monsters on the
block producer JJ Abrams is currently
planning on turning Cloverfield into a
larger shared universe 10 Cloverfield
Lane was already a very loosely
connected sequel or spin-off of
Cloverfield and currently there's
another film in development called god
particle that will also be a part of the
series paramount is planning on
releasing a new Cloverfield Universe
film every year the first conjuring film
was a surprise hit when it came out in
2013 now the studio is building a mini
conjuring universe that includes
Annabelle the creepy doll and currently
in development a film about the nun from
the con
to the Star Wars universe isn't exactly
new but it is expanding rapidly with the
success of rogue one Disney is filing
ahead with more spin-offs alongside the
traditional episodes the next one will
be about a young consult the most
surprising shared universe on this list
would have to go to the hanna-barbera
universe the first film will be a
scooby-doo reboot in 2018 after that
supposedly there will be a shared
universe that includes the Jetsons The
Smurfs The Flintstones and more are
there any other potential shared
universes you wish were out there
personally I'd love to see Charlotte's
Coronas character in the fate of the
Furious turn out to be furiosa from Mad
Max fury road there's just so much fury
unfortunately the two properties are
owned by different Studios so it's
probably not going to happen what do you
think of all the shared universes are
you a fan or would you rather just see a
standalone movie let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe